Now, I should say that if we take this grammar here,
and if I have this function to define grammars, and if I write a function to parse,
I can take this and if I have an expression like m * x + b, I'm going to parse it just great.
Unfortunately, with this description just as it is,
I would have trouble with m * x + b with spaces in between it,
because nowhere here did I say that spaces can occur between tokens.
In some grammars you're free to put spaces everywhere,
and in other grammars you aren't.
If I want this grammar function to be useful, I should be able to tell which is which.
I'm going to show a new version of grammar that takes that into account.
Here it is. There are two things you should notice about it right away.
First is that I add an optional parameter to say you can specify
what white space is allowed in between tokens.
Here it's saying s* is allowed--any number of spaces--zero or more.
You could change that if you have a different type of grammar you're defining.
Secondly, have much longer documentation here--
a documentation string describing what the language is.
Third, I've added one more statement here, which says if there are any tabs in the input,
replace them with spaces. Why did I do that?
Notice that I'm splitting here an arrow surrounded by spaces
and an or bar surrounded by spaces.
If somebody had written something and used a tab there rather than a space,
that would be really hard to debug. I don't want to have to force them to debug it.
I want to do the debugging for them and make that not be an error at all.